shops in the Venezuelan capital smashed
up and picked clean of their contents at
this supermarket in southeastern Caracas
people accused of taking food including
pasta rice and tomato sauce were among
those later arrested by security forces
for looting scenes of desperation like
this are becoming more commonplace in
the crisis hit South American nation all
compounded by a day's long power outage
[Music]
medicines were already in short supply
now reports that the blackout has led to
patients dying in hospitals are also
fueling rising anger at the government's
inaction crisis in Venezuela has a first
and last name in its Nicolas Maduro it's
time to understand that the humanitarian
crisis is not political it's social
Venezuelans are dying because there are
no solutions meanwhile those fortunate
enough to get power from a generator are
finding new uses for their refrigerators
a refrigerator where we're storing food
but it can also fit medicines there are
many people who need to store them at
least as far as insulin is concerned my
name's Willie Nana but many businesses
have been without power for days with
their fridges off food is rotting on the
shelves forcing many shop owners to cut
their losses I'm giving this all away
yesterday I gave away pizza today I'll
give all this to the kids on the street
as the crippling blackout drags on so
does the blame game between the
opposition and the president all
Venezuelans can do now is wait for good
news